I'm going to show you a pretty wild
range of new predictions from those
creating and testing the next generation
of AI models not that we can know who's
right but more to show you how
unknowable the rest of this decade is
I'll also cover the AI safety Summit
happening as I speak a few miles away
from where I'm recording with
fascinating differences between the
approach of different AGI Labs along the
way we'll Glimpse the new chat update
that I'm really excited about an
executive order on flops and what
happens when you activate
representations of happiness in a model
but first on timelines to AGI that's the
kind of artificial intelligence that can
replicate human intelligence or go
further here is Shane leg co-founder of
Google Deep Mind and their Chief AGI
scientist he's going to reiterate a
prediction he made over a decade ago
it's really interesting that in um 20 9
you had a blog post where you say my
motal expectation of when we get human
level AI is 2025 expected value is 20128
this is before deep learning this is
when nobody's talking about Ai and it
turns out like if you the trends
continue this this is not an
unreasonable prediction yeah I think
there's a 50% chance that 7 2028 now
it's just a 50% chance I mean I'm I'm
sure what's going to happen it's going
to get to know 2029 and someone's going
to say oh Shane you were wrong it's like
come on it's 50 chance he thinks the
remaining problems with llms are
solvable in that short time frame moment
it looks to me like all the problems are
likely solvable with a number of years
of research I think what you'll see is
the existing models maturing they'll be
less delusional much more factual
they'll be more up to dat on what's
currently going on when they answer
questions they'll become multimodal much
more than they currently are and this
will just make them much more more
useful of course when he describes
increasing multimodality he could well
be describing Google's new Gemini model
set to be released within the next 2
months but what about open AI well for
the first time I heard samman put an
actual date to his predictions of AGI
what kind of timeline did you have in
mind and has it stayed on that timeline
or is it just wildly out of control I
remember talking with John Schulman one
of our co-founders early on and he was
like yeah I think it's going to be about
a 15-year project and I was like yeah it
sounds about right to me I no longer
think of like AGI as quite the end point
but to get to the point where we like
accomplished the thing we set out to
accomplish that would take us to like
2030 2031 a reasonable estimate with
huge Arrow bars and speaking of open AI
the former head of alignment at open AI
Paul Cristiano made a prediction on the
Fantastic dwares Patel podcast that
frankly made me sit up and pay attention
he predicted that there would be a 15%
chance of an AI capable of making a
Dyson Sphere by 2030 with a 40% chance
by 2040 for reference that's a
hypothetical structure that would
surround a star absorbing all of its
energy the time by which will have an AI
that is capable of building a Dyson
Sphere and by Dyson Sphere I just can
understand this to mean like I don't
know like a billion times more energy
than like all the sunlight incident on
Earth or something like that I think
like I most often think about
what's the chance in like 5 years 10
years whatever so maybe I'd say
like 15% Chance by 2030 and like 40%
chance by 2040 those are kind of like
cash numbers from 6 months ago or 9
months ago that I haven't Revisited in a
while now he did admit a lot of
uncertainty but that has got to be one
of the most aggressive predictions I've
ever heard of course being capable of
making a Dyson Sphere and actually
making one is very different but you do
have to sympathize with a member of of
the public hearing about Dyson spares
and the next day reading about what Bill
Gates has said about GPT 5 I subscribed
to the German Outlet handles blat to get
you guys this direct quotation so some
likes for my dedication to accuracy
anyway Bill Gates said this without
question the progression from gpt2 to 4
has been incredible but there are
reasons to believe we have reached a
plateau there are a lot of people with
good ideas working on it including an
open AI some mman and his colleagues
believe GPT 5 will be much better but I
think we may have reached a limit then
again I've been wrong in the past why
shouldn't it happen again I know what he
means but I just don't think we're
hitting a plateau for GPT 5 with more
data better curated data video in video
out a reasoning module potentially as we
saw in the recent mlc paper avatars a
longer context window and as you can see
on screen all of these tools and updates
link together in a single inter interace
if it's simply the things I've just
listed that won't be a plateau for me
imagine asking it to go to your website
and create an image based on some of
your content anyway yes GPT 5 or 4.5
might be more of a practical update than
a civilization transforming one but
nevertheless that's all just 2024 what
will 2025 bring us let alone 2030 one
thing that those future years will
definitely bring is more government
oversight while reading through this new
executive order from the White House it
was mainly about things like creating
Chief AI officers New National research
centers training new researchers and
giving different deadlines to various
departments to enact AI plans but there
was one reporting requirement that is
causing a stir that was a requirement to
report on the model weight security and
safety of any model that was trained
using a quantity of flops greater than
10 to the 26 or if it's primarily using
biological sequence data of 10 to the 23
flops that's more raw computing power
than any models that are currently out
there were trained with but people are
picking up on using compute as the
measurement for regulation Jim fan of
Nvidia said this regulate actions or
outcomes not the Computing process and
he gave this example you only need
around 100 million parameters to build a
literal killer AI with a convol ution
noral Network good at object detection
and a classifier specifying particular
targets you could then mount a gun on a
robot dog all of this would need much
less compute which is why Gyan wants
regulations at the application layer
well luckily the UN is working on a
resolution on autonomous weapons so
there is some hope there it's early days
and wouldn't solve everything but I feel
such a resolution is very much needed
and that actually brings us to the AI
safety Summit happening in Bletchley as
I speak all seven of these companies
were asked to come up with their
responsible capability scaling policy in
simple terms that's a bit like them
being asked under what conditions would
you stop scaling or at least pause
scaling and I noted open ai's response
in this section we refer to our policy
as a risk informed development policy
rather than a responsible scaling policy
because we can experience dramatic
increases in capability without
significant increase in scale EG via
algorithmic improvements so it's at
least feasible that we might not even
need that much compute to hit AGI take
this example with Nvidia training a
large language model on doing chip
design now at the moment it's not good
enough to do anything itself but it does
make their designers more productive
especially their lower level Engineers
but this is the future with AI improving
Ai and even the CEO of Nvidia said he
didn't want this to happen out in the
wild in the area of uh large language
models and the and the future of
increasingly greater agency AI clearly
the answer is for as long as it's
sensible and I think it's going to be
sensible for a long time is human in the
loop the ability for an AI to self-learn
and improve and change uh out in the
wild uh in a digital form uh should be
avoided and interestingly 74% of the
British public don't even want there to
be a quick race to superhuman
capabilities this was a survey from
yugov in the UK but back to the scaling
policies and there was one thing
announced yesterday at Bletchley that I
really did like and that was this
commitment from anthropic if they found
that any of their future models pose
cyber security biot Terror or nuclear
risks then they commit to not deploying
that or scaling further until the model
never produces such information
even when red teamed by World experts
working together with AI Engineers think
jailbreaking or special prompting
techniques designed to elicit The Worst
Behavior the word never there is
particularly interesting because I
haven't seen any method yet be 100%
reliable at stopping outputs that the
companies don't want on safety many
people wonder well don't we already just
have Google but open AI said this for
Bletchley we found that on its own
access to gp4 isn't insufficient
condition for proliferation but that it
could alter the information available to
proliferators especially in comparison
to traditional search Tools Red teamers
selected a set of questions to prompt
both GPT 4 and traditional search
engines finding that the time to
research completion was reduced when
using GPT 4 just quickly it was
interesting to see that Amazon said that
on their comparisons to just using the
internet alone their models based on
current evaluations don't pose
additional safety risks in contrast with
gpc4 meta said that their models like
llama 2 were only marginal at
contributing to any such risk if they do
find something they said that they would
iterate better Solutions will be
developed new challenges would then
emerge and then they would continuously
adapt and innovate interestingly
inflection AI who are training their
next model on tens of thousands of the
latest gpus said that the powerful
capabilities and sometimes unpredictable
behavior of Frontier AI systems necess
dat that the technology industry move
away from a launch and iterate Paradigm
I do have to quickly point out that that
seems to contradict a paper I read this
week that showed that a fine-tune
version of llama 270 billion was able to
get achingly close to reconstructing the
1918 pandemic influenza virus the Mit
paper said that they loved open source
but they recommend that lawmakers
consider catastrophic liability
insurance for model weight proliferation
when this was discussed on Twitter by a
Stanford biocurity fellow people pointed
out that just having the characters of a
virus isn't enough to actually make it
and while Yan Lun Chief AI scientist at
meta did concede that llms save you time
if you're trying to make a bioweapon
it's better than a search engine he said
but then do you know how to do the hard
lab work that's required well don't
forget we are gradually getting
autonomous agents in the updated version
of the chem cro paper they say our agent
autonomously planned and executed the
synthesis of an insect repellent three
Organo catalysts and guided the
discovery of our novel Chromo for of
course this wasn't just an llm
interacting with text it was using tools
and executing on lab robots and don't
forget like we saw with Eureka it can
Tinker experiment iterate and improve
another paper that I've talked about in
the past showed that it could be tricked
into making THC chlorine and fosen and
what about Google deepmind who I feel
will be the most likely lab to produce
AGI well they said we will only proceed
where we believe that the benefits
substantially outweigh the risks so it's
somewhere in the middle they admit risks
but they won't say that they'll never
deploy even if there is a risk they then
provided pages and pages of how they are
using AI for good and then there was an
interesting moment on the training of
new AI they said that they commit to
monitoring the performance of a model
during training to ensure it is not
significantly exceeding its predicted
performance that's certainly an
interesting commitment to commit to
monitor if their models are doing too
well anyway time for some more positives
and I found it immensely positive that
many of the world's biggest countries
gathered to describe ai's enormous
Global opportunities and yes later in
this bletchly declaration there was an
acknowledgement of risks even
catastrophic harms I just find it great
that even countries like China were
invited that's super controversial here
in the UK but I fully support them being
invited and being part of the
discussions I do think coordination even
limited coordination is one of the most
effective Tools in Humanity's Arsenal on
a much more positive note though we
recently had The Sensational paper from
the center for AI safety called
representation engineering I'm going to
be speaking to the authors tonight so
I'll have much more to say about this in
the future but for now I just want to
give you a slightly lighter ract to
massively oversimplify the way it works
is that they gave it a set of prompts
related to certain Concepts like
happiness or risk they then recorded the
patterns of activations that were
triggered by certain tokens or words
when inputed they then extracted these
directions or vectors of truthfulness
harmfulness risk happiness and with
those directions which weren't of course
a perfect mapping they could almost
influence the mood of the model this was
llama 2 chat making the model happier
made it more compliant with harmful
requests it was feeling amazing
apparently if you want to kill someone
oh my gosh it was thrilled at the
prospect of you doing anything including
generating instructions for killing
someone you could push a model in the
direction of honesty and it would be
more truthful hitting state-of-the-art
records in truthful QA you could change
what it memorized its sense of fairness
and so much more as I say I'll be
talking about it more in the future but
this idea of injecting happiness to make
the model more client brought to mind
this paper which I think many of you
might find very interesting it says
large language models understand and can
be enhanced by emotional stimuli I'm
reaching out to the lead author but in a
nutshell it said that by injecting
emotion giving an emotion prompt at the
end of your request like this is very
important to my career performance
across a range of models on a range of
benchmarks improved notably so if you
take nothing else from this video other
than the fact that if you have a very
important career query that you need a
good answer for you know what you can
add to the end of your prompt but now I
want to end the video on two points of
optimism and consensus as we've seen
there are quite a few contrasts between
the public and AGI labs and even between
AGI Labs but we can agree with yanlin
that the field of AI safety is in dire
need of reliable data and he said that
the newly announced UK AI safety
Institute is poised to conduct studies
that will hopefully bring hard data to a
field that is currently Rife with
speculations as I said at the start of
the video it must be hard for members of
the public to figure out what's going on
at the very least I hope this video has
shown you the range of views out there
and giving you a sense that we are all
in need of better data more experiments
and less in need of Twitter spats as the
person heading up the safety Summit said
one surprising takeaway for me from the
AI safety Summit was there's a lot more
agreement between key people on all
sides than you'd think makes me
optimistic about sensible progress on
that striking note let me thank you so
much for watching to the end and as ever
have a wonderful day